oh let kev exclusive yo you already know
what it is man this is big shine and you
listening to my dog that's right my
homie bootleg cast yo man I 975 Ready
Set Radio man bootleg cab live in studio
with my dual big show what up son you
got damn right man cuz we've been homies
for a while was good i'm chillin brother
you back in vegas it's like your second
home man yeah i've been here three times
this year man with that within the 40
how many days has it been this year 48
days like februari man 48 days I've been
here three times this year man gone
that's what it is man I want to give you
a big shout out because I've been a fan
for a long time and finally famous it
was such a marathon to get it out now
you got three number one singles and
shut everybody I think it did the right
thing I think it did what I wanted to do
not I could take it to another level
with the artist treatment and that's
what I'm really excited about to be able
to grow from there and then go hard I
really feel out my new music is more
reminiscent of like my earlier work but
just like way better because I'm a way
better rapper now so I think that's the
best way to do it you know to really to
go back to man cut your phone off man I
know just laying to really take me back
to you know what got me to where I am
and just take it to another level now on
the new album the last album there was
there was no Kanye beat huh the new
album coming is it is it going to be
some kind of a production yeah it's
gonna be some kind of a production man
we had a couple Kanye productions for
the first one but just didn't make they
make the cut some someone got sample
clearance couldn't get the sample clear
in time and the other one we just didn't
think it fit the album so yeah we got a
lot of stuff on deck man and are you
still gonna be working with no ID cuz I
think y'all got the winning formula man
hell yeah odd for sure man but we got
i'm working with a lot with my producer
i just signed key wane he's coming up
with a lot of just great stuff and no ID
man we got a son that's gonna change the
world mean really yeah can you tell us a
little bit about it
it's very just like inspiring man and
you know the inspiration when you
inspire when you can inspire that's the
best thing to do this message because
inspire people I could tell you soon as
inspirational record that's going to
change the world I could tell you that I
rap from a crazy perspect from one verse
i read from perspective and other verse
i rap from like a crazy perspective i'm
looking forward to this ice i kind of
like a concept record a little bit is
the concept burgers crazy man it's like
my favorite record any features like
down for the new album oh yeah um we got
on there but we got on there you mess up
Wiz Wiz it was on there yeah it's a
couple crazy ones I wanting to let out
the bag just you know one crazy when you
get up back why don't you know Kanye's
on the court all right um who else um I
want to say one but I just to say I
can't yeah man it's gonna be crazy cab
you know I'm gonna bring you an
exclusive no seriously man I'm not just
saying I will make sure i send you one
exclusive and being you pop it all
inside that cave exclusive hey so um you
are on the MTV's top 10 hottest MC list
yeah uh you're a number eight mmm which
I you know I thought was dope man cuz I
really thought that hope is number six
that which is insane but um you were
just you last year you opened up for Wiz
on on the rolling paper store now you
know you're technically hotter than him
according to MTV i'ma let your brother
how does it feel to kind of like you
know grow from from that too now man
you're a superstar now you feel me like
you're one of had a student on the
planet thanks man listen that's a hell
of a compliment um man i just it feels
good it feels good to be at the
forefront of his new thing i was called
talking to j Cole yesterday we was
kicking it we got robbed by the way on
that list no definitely yeah yeah I said
did you hear did you see me when I
chatted with empty nah I chatted with it
with the people at the thing and say Amy
I'll tripping for not putting jokester
on them like I love while 82 but I I
mean Jake hose down when gold
looking separate separate discussion
yeah but the thing is so but you know um
i'll talk about cole and it's just tight
man because me and j Cole went back
years man we was performing for 30
people and me same while Amy and while a
or me and uh even Tiger man I remember
tiger came to the tray years ago he was
riding around my broke ass Chevy in the
tray recording like that like this is my
homies Mac Miller with all these kids
are like my dogs from years ago before
anything popped off so to see it all
happening it's like but it's like
running the game now you can't even
imagine like how crazy it is man so it
is just tied to be a part of it I'm
happy to be here and I'm really gonna
take it to new heights you know I I feel
like for my first album I could have
took it way further man I couldn't oh
you know art it's always feel like they
could've did way better which I know I
could not your first album was dope man
my favorite record don't tell me you
love me that's my joint though man yeah
that man we should shot video for that
but ah we got songs that's like I met if
you came to the studio in the city songs
you would be so happy dog you need to
come to LA on Monday and listen city
song so that's what i'mma be playing
them do that man for real man because I
want to get your opinion because I
always say like its new and it's crazy
but when people come in there what do
people expressions be i mean j Cole was
sitting listening to anyone's like
madness it's like incredible I can't
wait but it's really matter i'm really
excited about I really worked my ass off
for it so like I can't wait to just take
it to a new height and like everybody
who hating like just shut them to [__]
up and just like everybody would be
talking [__] like thank you for thinking
shut everybody to [__] I'm not yet not
sure I did 12 months everybody made big
sean ain't gonna get gonna drop his
album yeah like I gave a machine like
that I was like the first one I was one
of the first ones to drop the I'm like I
think me drama I'm kind of led to a
chain of like yo yo we gotta drop these
albums like people these these people
going on by the [__] it's not just the
internet you know yeah so you know and
I'm my audience has quadrupled since
then man so I'm just had man congrats I
wanted to ask you I just saw a video
about a month ago or so um
there was a video that got put out of
the first time kanye played jay-z the
big brother record and you were in the
studio like five years ago six years ago
just post it up like writing mm-hmm um
can can you tell us about that that time
period were you were you were like
nobody you know like at that point the
only thing you had oh no Big Sean out
nah didn't I'm just in the studio
working with Kanye man and it was like
y'all this big sean he looks so young
he's in the right and you know the guys
and I remember that man I remember the
studio jaywalked in a mom you know I
never met Jay I was like speechless of
course Kanye had me wrapped for him like
off rip and Jay I remember I tried for
Jay and he was like good job man and
then he hit me on the shoulder yard so
he was like keep it up man keep it up
and I could tell he pi didn't like it
that much but you know he's just being
nice and um man calle always believed in
me since back then and that's what I'm
saying like I don't think people
understand like that was during the
recording process to graduation and that
was what like he just took me under his
wing just so I could see like the
recording process so I could like you
know just so I can observe how to make
it albumen well all that goes into in
the details and you know uh some stuff
that I learned there that I'm really
using now on this album particularly my
first album man i was really caught in
the world when I was people were like
label had me doing a lot of things my
mind was spread I was going through
stuff with my girl I was going through
stuff with my family I was going through
financial issues I was going through all
this [__] that light really had an
effect on the album and its greatness I
feel like now I feel like everything is
in order my management order
everything's in order so this album is
flowing so great man and like the
stories on it the stuff that people are
going to be able to relate to this the
bangers on there let's pick the songs
people gonna party to man it's like I'm
too I can't wait to put it up I can't
wait to hear my brother I'm gonna try to
make it out to LA on Monday good news
come out hey I swear man if you gonna
come to my mom was close I gotta holler
at the boss lady like you Rita I guess
manly man it's gonna be crazy I'm
definitely looking forward to checking
it out I'm trying to make it out the
good music album before I let you go
without dropping I don't know when his
dropping me i know i went in on that
[__] though I'm shout out to uh the dude
who produced the first single is from
Phoenix yeah you know oh yeah lift lift
lift it yeah man meal if they got some
other stuff coming out to H yo he's I'm
from Phoenix so um he's made a rap group
called the formula when I was a kid you
told me yeah yeah so it's just crazy
it's so crazy only killing me is so
crazy like such a good look for this for
the city he's a beast you know what I'm
saying so shout out to phoenix man shout
out to the west shout out to LA shout
out to Vegas man we've lifted we got
some stuff there's me and him Max is my
mother drop like next week really I
suppose if that's what it is when that's
my dog man shout out to lift it and uh
may I went in on that song this line
right to hear it man hey man you gotta
you gotta get going man thank you for
coming through I know you're trying to
stop again some chipotle not on oh yeah
you already know a man make sure y'all
man give we bout to drop new mixtapes
new albums knew everything make sure
y'all go pick up wale album and go pick
up tiger album mac miller album Jake
well boom support the new the new
movement everybody man get my album
stealing stores okay you know everybody
everybody just doing anything this new
movement and I'd like to just throw this
out there man I'd be awesome if my
poster was on the new yeah of course man
of course Mike me I'm on my posters next
single to man so okay hey what's up I
don't know if I spoiled that for him but
amen it's all good yeah I do those shine
you already know all by the way you know
Mike Posner wrote half a half of the
course on don't tell me let me oh we did
yeah so he was supposed to be on it but
then I just wanted to sing him I so such
a great song man yeah yeah that's a
great song I related that record so much
man i'm really jealous this is my life
right yeah no yeah thanks man but a mint
have a good show tonight trey songz you
guys are gonna make the ladies go crazy
tonight male yeah man come on make sure
you come to you coming through right
here yeah I'll be there man you come
through man you'd be coming to the club
with me every time to me where I always
hit you up doll you much love me Russ do
it Sinai 75 big sean boy